ось це якщо чесно вже дістав
підленькі жарти тому що він диявол
тому що він напад я ніколи не
чув від президента порошенка, щоб він
казав він назвав себе кримським
тому татарином тому ми чутливо
ставилися вже перебуваючи у в'язниці
радянський союз з усією силою по скільки
років тобі дадуть
адвокат приносив ці відомості тримала
твої від тебе не кине кримнаш клинський
чи готові ми скоро побачимося і тільки
прошу про одне, щоб у мене дочекався
є дуже великі сумніви
добрий вечір шановні youtube глядачі
ми зараз такий час ось поставимо
останні півтора роки
знаходимося в постійному в постійному
такому стані скандалів до чого не
заява там президента чи його
оточення і навіть не встигаєш
сфокусуватися на чомусь тому що
слідом після одного скандалу йде другий
потім ще якісь як вони це називають
хайпові речі
[музика]
ось це якщо чесно вже дістала до
президент країни вселенські вирішив ще
раз ось у кинути в суспільство ось свою
таку
печію вже на тлі повного провалу по
всім напрямам його діяльності
команди він вирішив звинуватити
опонентів привласнити собі лаври
щодо криму це до нього робили
ряд політиканів там пальто лагів ті хто
краватки ледве до або ще щось там
знаєте трохи непорядно чинити я в
ті роки
чотирнадцятий рік за мою позицію як і в
багатьох моїх співвітчизників мене мене
посадили в тих умовах, коли ти ловиш
ті шматочки новин які йдуть з
україни і вони дуже всі такі
емоційні та всі пов'язані з успіхами
так як весь світ сконцентрувався навколо
україни так в Україні президент веде
себе як полководець командувач та й
дає відсіч ворогові і ти бачиш це все як
дратує твоїх ворогів у руках яких
ти знаходишся а в той же час ми
спостерігали я включаючи ви зелінський
у той період керівник кварталу 95
коли вся
всі українці стали на захист свій
батьківщини ви в цей час відпустки
жарти мерзенний на адресу своєї ж країни
ви тоді не були президентом
але ви валик ви були якщо ви вважали себе
громадянином України
то ви повинні були замислюватися, що ці
жарти підленькі жарти ображають і
принижують дуже велику частину
українського народу, який проливає
кров за свою країну який перебуваючи
купуватися і бореться і втрачає життя і
потрапляють висновок так ось я ніколи не
чув від президента порошенка, щоб він
говорив я ось стільки зробив і в тому
номер для криму але я добре пам'ятаю як
ставши президентом з високої трибуни
конгресу американська де своїм
виступі він назвав себе кримським
татарином
а ми коментатор брудно findet у днів
книги вам машину
[оплески]
[музика]
так добре повний як звільнялися
військово полонений тисячами до цього ми
чутливо ставилися вже перебуваючи в
в'язниці тому що адвокат приносив ці
відомості та це давало надію що країна
тримала твої від тебе не кине і
абсолютно було однаково скільки років
тобі дадуть
ти точно знав що ось з таким
президентом ця країна
додай сиру і звільнить і території
а що твоє життя окремо взяте
людини в порівнянні з тим, що сотні
тисяч своїх співвітчизників живуть з
очікуванням звільнення ось ці всі
очікування вони асоціювалися з
президентом порошенком що з вами
асоціюється я вам у двері хто скажу
ще за роздумують у криму бірж з наших
стиглих громадян вони в шоці
від тих змін
який з вами прийшли
від тих меседжів, які вони постійно
чують від вас і від вашої команди та про
воду яку потрібно дати на
окупанту щоб його посилити там щоб
йому комфортніше було наші громадяни
просять води не просять якусь
гуманітарну допомогу
наші громадяни борються вмирають і сидять у
в'язницях для того щоб їх as щоб
звільнити від окупанта, щоб вигнали
його
давай молодець так
[музика]
наші моряки намагалися увійти до азовського
своє море зі свого чорного моря до свого
Азовське море
викликайте як сприйняли ось цей як
назвали його росіяни інциндент і
і це це це повторювалося вашій команді
теж інциндент не це не інциндент це
військовий злочинний бандитський напад
ворога на наш корабель і
але при цьому в криму наші
співвітчизники це сприйняли як от
початок ось такого сміливого рішучого
військової присутності у наших водах та
коли моряків заарештували
першими на допомогу зібралися в основному
кримські татари і коли їх уночі а я
відстежував знаючи всі правила в'язниці я
відстежував щоб цих хлопців там ось у
цій сімферопольській в'язниці щоб їх не
пресували і їх тієї ж ночі вивезли в
лефортово
за ними поїхали наші громадяни
україни кримські татари поїхали до львів
лефортово не злякалися і стали під
стінами та лефортово привезли
передачі щоб допомогти і найголовніше
показати що вони не одні
[музика]
що ми відчували і як сприймали
санкції, які вводилися під тиском
в першу чергу
президента порошенка всі ми вважали що
можливо потрібно було жорсткіше щоб
наші партнери реагували але теж
час ми бачили як роздратовані окупанти
і до лаборантів такими діями збоку
президента порошенка тому вони його
ненавиділи вони мені у в'язниці відкрито
говорили про те, давали зрозуміти що цей
перший ворог окупантів Росії та знаєте
це гордість вселяла
що твого полководця ворог поважає і
боїться тому що він сильний
а за ним стоїть держава україна яка
показує зуби силу що такого ворога
як росію якого побоюються багато
до країни, а він сказав в обличчя
ворогів путіну, що ми обов'язково переможемо
і повернемо свою територію звільнив з
Увійти
росія купила на крим який бу і буду
українською
[музика]
[оплески]
я кілька слів хочу сказати про всіх
гучний кримській платформі
всі хто зараз дали згоду на участь
у такому форматі з питання
окупованого криму вони всі ці сім
років активно підтримують
нас україни та кримських татар це всі хто
зараз ви звертаєтеся вони завжди
голосують
у всіх міжнародних інституціях
проти Росії на підтримку України і ми
чекаємо від цієї кримської платформи не
ритуального такого характеру про
конкретиці
і ось тут у мене є дуже великі
сумніви що результат
самі кримської платформи буде
досить жорстким і продуктивним чому
ну тому що ось ці півтора роки
показали що ви в очах путіна
мабуть ви в ці очі так дивіться що
хочете побачити те що вам ближче
взагалі-то я дотримуюсь і підтримую
позицію президента Америки байдена
який у вічі подивившись у вічі путіна
не побачив душі, бо він диявол
тому що він приступив
тому що на ньому кров сотень сотень
тисяч людей він дає накази знищувати
жінок і дітей це він винний у смерті
дітей, батьки яких знаходяться на його
наказом у таборах Росії це наші
співвітчизники
наші громадяни України він винний смерті
наших матерів які не дочекавшись зі
сльозами вмирали і ось коли ваші
меседжі слухаєш і ваші вашого
оточення
то ось потім з'являються ці дуже
великі сумніви я зрубаю все
українець ще б не плакав потяг і знаєте
я з ваших вуст низ не чув чіткого
відповіді чи ми пиши з цього питання крим
захопила бандитська росія.
це що їй не змогли дати відсіч
в той період це ось всі ті
непослідовністю не
зацікавленістю
до 14-го року з моменту набуття
незалежності після розпаду СРСР влади
яка формувалася в Україні
ви в одному з інтерв'ю сказали, що ви не
вважаєте, що зміна статусу криму
якимось чином вплинути на до
окупацію криму я вас запевняю у криму
кримські татари та громадяни українців живуть
з однією думкою щоб позбутися від
окупанта та боротьбу кримсько-татарського
народу за свою батьківщину і за свій тримай
державу України дуже сильно б на кшталт
зміцнило б ось ухвалення цих законів і
я впевнений що це сильно би допомогло
українцям самим коли кажуть вони що
крим наш український це був дуже сильно
би допомогло нашим
на нашій державі закріпити свої
позиції на міжнародних майданчиках
перед нашими партнерами це б сильно
вдарило ви по нашому ворогові путіну
це б сильно вдарило б по наших ворогів
який окупували крим чому
ви не робите чому ви за півтора роки
упустивши стільки часу зараз намагаєтеся
як ваше інтерв'ю ви сказали що крім
а ми ще від вас нічого продуктивного
покриваю бачили що крім вас чи до вас
криму
ніхто не займатися
[музика]
шановні глядачі часто запитують
коли крим повернеться я відразу завжди
відповідаю що треба говорити коли крим
звільнимо ми кримські татари нас не
чекали у крим після депортації але ми
кинулися ми жили крим ми народжувалися не
бачачи крим
але вже жили крим ми чекали на талон
мить коли ось вона настане і ми
увірвемося у крим це був 8 7 рік коли
ще радянський союз з усією силою
тоталітарних каральних органів кгб та
мвд та інше але ми пішли вко
пішли тому що в Росії під тиском
як тоді говорили західного світу
почалися ледь помітні зміни і ми
нікого не питали
ми не чекали, що хтось нам якимсь
законодавчим актом чи якимись
домовленостями відкриє шлях додому ми
рвонулися додому та ви за кожен такий
крок платили життя але ми дійшли до будинку та
ми повернулися на батьківщину так зараз
багато говорять про росію, що вона в
стан якихось змін не може
злочинець руб у якого руки все по
шиї він сам у крові весь знаходиться мова
все одно караєва наздожене і вчорашній
лояльний до шляху президент Америки
народ Америки змінив вибрав іншого
котрий знає як я вже сказав з яким
дияволом має відношення вона що ми
готові за ці півтора роки
чи готові ми використати маленький шанс
для того, щоб фізично увійти в крим
показати що крим це україна
а до чого ми взагалі готові ми за півтора
року від вас не почули до чого ми готові
як багато хто говорить ось настане цей cos
x на що ми готові це питання до вас
президент зелений період президента
порошенка ми ставили питання щодо
характеру зміни України все сильніше
і все відчутніше
ролі України була світі наші претензії
очікування були більше висот зараз ми
більше тривоги
і в тривозі за саму Україну я кожне
ранок у камері
проспався від стуку
ось цих залізних дверей залізних дверей
про їх перевіряльники відкривали
і прокидався в такому
сум'яття тому що я всю ніч ось
скільки там спав три чотири години я пішов
по вахті сараю
і перші кілька секунд для густава
як мене розбудять я приходив до тями і
побачив над собою нору і розумів що я в
Але цей сон мене не залишав все
три коди
та це дало мені впевненість що я вийду
з в'язниці я вищий за мене звільни до речі
президент порошенко домовився з
президентом Туреччини зараз я коли дзвоню
додому батькові
а йому 84 роки
і
раніше я після звільнення я йому
говорив ми скоро побачимося
а зараз я йому говорю щоб обов'язково
[музика]
і тільки прошу про одне щоб мене
дочекався
[музика]